-Welcome back!
-Thank you!
-So happy to have you here.
-I'm happy to be here.
-I want to talk about
this wonderful film,
but I would be remiss
not to ask you this,
because I know we talked
about "The Sopranos"
last time you were here.
It's just been announced
David Chase is going to make a
prequel movie to "The Sopranos,"
called
"The Many Saints of Newark."
Is that as exciting to you
as it is to me?
-That's already
more than I knew.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know the title.
-So I should have said,
"Spoiler alert."
-Yeah.
-I feel like I didn't realize --
-A little late for that.
-[ Laughs ]
-But -- No, I just found out
about it like everybody else.
It's, you know, the story,
I guess, of Tony's parents
and Uncle Junior
when they were kids.
-So, there's no baby Carmela?
You don't have to worry about --
-You know, I put in
my picture and résumé.
That's all I can do.
-Okay, that's great.
[ Laughter ]
This is a wonderful film.
This is -- you play
a high school teacher
who is helping an ex-student
get out of jail.
-Right.
-And doing advocacy work
despite the fact
that you have
your own family
and your own job.
What drew you
to a role like this?
-I worked with Jay Duplass --
sort of worked with him --
on a movie called "Landline."
We weren't in scenes together,
but I met him
and he's just charming and
darling and sweet.
-And a wonderful actor, yeah.
-And a fantastic actor.
They said he co-wrote it
and was starring in it,
which was amazingly great.
And then I read the script,
and it's the way
people really talk
and it seemed to be
the way people really live.
And that's the kind of stuff
I respond to,
so that was it.
-That's fantastic.
I know one thing that it had
that you don't love is
you actually had to go to
Washington state to shoot it.
-Yes. Big challenge for me.
-Because you love
being in New York, right?
-You know, I would like to say
that's what it is.
I think it's more that I don't
like being somewhere else.
-Okay, gotcha. That --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, i just don't like
leaving home.
And I have a family
and a life here.
And it's different from
when I was a little kid
and it was like, you know,
"Pack your bag,
and we're going to shoot a movie
in, you know, Timbuktu.
And it's just
those days are gone.
-Right. You like being home.
You like being in New York.
And you have been in New York
for a long time.
-Long time.
-I read an interview with you,
and I was thrilled to hear
the way that you used to
get around New York City,
which is rollerblades.
-Oh, yeah.
-Is this true?
-For many, many years.
-Wow, wow!
-Rollerblades and chain smoking.
-Wow, that is --
-It really was like...
[ Laughter ]
Seriously. Seriously.
-I feel like there was, like,
a day where both of those became
outlawed in New York.
It was, like, the same day.
-And it didn't matter to me
at all, though.
It took me many years
to stop both of them.
-I was going to say,
it seems dangerous
to rollerblade in New York.
But if you were already
smoking a cigarette, like...
[ Laughter ]
You were obviously
looking death in the eye.
-Some sort of a death wish,
I guess.
-Yeah, for years I did that.
-And now a Vespa.
-Is that active?
Are you still...
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
I used it this afternoon.
I use it all the time.
It's the best way
to get around the city.
You're in and out of
appointments.
You pull between two cars,
you know?
It's just great.
-And you -- your kids --
Was there a time in your life
when your kids would ride
on the Vespa with you?
Would you have a kid
on the back?
The time was -- Today,
this afternoon, in fact.
-Oh, wow! That's great.
-Yeah, it is great.
I love it. You don't go --
You never get to go really fast.
-Right.
-You know?
-You must have a great
relationship with your kids
if they're willing to jump
on the back of the Vespa
with their mom.
I think that's a very...
-Well, they don't do it
willingly.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Mind you.
No, they actually
get a kick out of it.
-Well, I just feel bad
'cause they probably get
all the cigarette smoke, right?
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
-Oh, thank you.
-I'm just sayin'.
-So, do they --
they're 13 and 10?
-Yes.
-Son's 13, right?
-Right.
-Acting bug?
-Not at all, no.
-Really?
-I don't know even know if they
know that's what I do.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I just have
weird hours,
and I come home and
i have a lot of makeup on.
-But they don't ask, you know.
-Uh-huh.
-They saw me on a bus once, and
they were a little suspect,
but they didn't pursue it.
-Gotcha.
What do you think it is
that they pursue?
What are the -- At those ages,
what do they want To be?
-My son wants to be
a soccer star.
I'm not entirely sure he won't.
He's very good.
-Okay, that's exciting.
-I dare say.
My daughter wants to be
a pop star and a veterinarian.
-Oh, that's nice.
-So...
[ Laughter ]
By the time she's of age,
those two things
may somehow be combined.
I don't know.
-You're a dog lover.
-I'm a big animal lover, yeah.
-I have a dog, as well.
You took your dog
to a dog psychic.
-No!
-You didn't?
-That would make more sense.
-Okay.
-I spoke to a woman on the phone
who was in, I'm going to say,
North Dakota.
-Okay.
-And I think I had to send her
a picture first.
-Okay.
-And that's what we did.
-Oh, wait, so, she told you
what your dog was thinking
off a photo?
Why didn't she just --
-Can i just tell you?
This dog was a little teeny dog
I had rescued.
-Okay.
-And she was sick all the time.
And it turned out,
I found out later on,
that she was pregnant,
because she had been a mommy
in a puppy mill.
So, anyway, it was
a long, ugly story.
When I asked the woman,
she said, "Wait,
she's saying to me, 'They're
taking my babies,'
your dog is saying."
Which she knew
that my dog had been a mom,
like, many times.
It was crazy weird that
this woman knew these things.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
I mean, I totally bought it,
hook, line, and sinker.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't pay.
I didn't pay anything.
-You did-- Okay,
well, now, that --
-None the wiser.
I mean phone bill.
-So, this person just is, like,
running a terrible business
where...
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think
it's her business.
It might just be, like,
a little side thing he does.
I don't know.
-How did you find her?
-It was at somebody's --
like a -- I don't know --
a baby shower.
-Uh-huh.
-And a woman said, "Oh,
I know a dog psychic."
And it went like that.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-There was nothing
up until that point?
Nothing came up before that?
-You know, I barely remember
my children's names,
so give me a minute.
It was something like that.
-Gotcha.
-Yes.
-One thing that obviously
keeps you in New York
is when you do stuff --
stage stuff here.
-Yeah.
-I know you've done a lot
in the past.
Do you have anything coming up?
Is that something
you'd like to do again?
-I do, in fact.
I'm going to be doing a play
with the new group
in September, called "The True."
-That's exciting.
-And I don't even know if
I'm supposed to say that yet.
-Oh, that's exciting!
-But i just did, so...
-There you go.
-There you have it.
-Now it's out there.
-Yeah.
-You know who...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I actually already
knew about it,
because I talked to this woman
in North Dakota.
[ Laughter ]
I sent her -- Just before
I interview someone --
-Sent a picture of me.
-I sent her a picture of you.
-That's so good.
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "I don't know
about the dog,
but Edie is doing a play."
[ Laughter ]
"That much I know."
-Thank you so much
for being back.
-So happy to be here.